glad i had that cup of coffee i'm ready
to go on this one
let's go baby
[Music]
i'm clint howard and i'm this guy's
little brother i'm ron howard i'm this
fella's older brother
[Music]
yeah i was a whiz-bang troublemaker
school
just general principle you know i was
the little brother i was the hehe man
yeah he had great sense of humor it said
whatever was on his mind and for the
most part it worked beautifully for him
occasionally you know got him in a
little bit of trouble i played it
super safe i was kind of like goody two
[ __ ] and i got really good at dodging
bullets
yeah once in a while you know but i had
uh denied deny i didn't do it i deny
pretty good batting average of getting
slippery and getting away with it
[Music]
[Laughter]
i guess that's probably true because i
know
there's been a couple of pictures that
i've worked on that
god forbid he would not go there and
watch it
but i might pretend i did
hey you can't go wrong saying hey clint
you were very entertaining
[Music]
really i think so i mean look i i was a
good older brother they didn't show
favoritism i mean that's the blessing of
our of our relationship with our parents
they really loved us both for who we
were
appreciated us both you know for our
personalities our skills so they didn't
put that pressure on us
[Music]
i'm terrible with names it has nothing
to do with years all my life if i'm
directing a movie i honestly can't even
remember the names of all the characters
the written characters so they start to
become the actors to me more people make
fun of me it's always been like that
thank god for imdb yeah
[Music]
it's my own look it rotates you know i
kind of look the same all the time and
about every seven years it cycles
through and i i'm kind of with it and
then it it rotates back out and i'm kind
of am what i am and people have to be
patient with that fashion crusader you
know for the alleys it's kind of neat i
was notorious in high school for
the most ridiculous shirt
and of course the one rule they had for
high school graduation is you can't wear
thongs i'm stepping and my thong is just
perfectly like up in the air just
flopping away and by thong we mean
flip-flops yes oh no no no
no
really yeah
i've always loved tv i direct primarily
movies we do movies and television and
of course i grew up primarily acting on
tv shows i like the weather channel it's
pretty that's pretty good it's good good
programming
[Music]
as an actor watching you youth act young
guys in their 20s and and girls in their
20s when i identify the spark when i
identify that wow
they have they're sharing something that
is behind the eyes and it's you know i
used to have my my actors my favorite
actors jack nicholson you know and the
al pacino and de niro and now i'm seeing
this new generation quite often i'll be
working with some young actor and i'll
go my god he's really good when you do
the work that
that we do you're always growing you're
always asking questions you're always
trying to figure things out as a
filmmaker
you know i choose projects that are
going to challenge me i don't i don't
make movies about things that i fully
understand i tend to make movies about
things that i have a sense of but a lot
of curiosity about and it takes me to
you know all kinds of places i learned a
hell of a lot and then i like to share
that with audiences because it's not
it's not an expert lecturing it's
somebody who's kind of saying hey
you know you're probably a lot like me
look what i look what i discovered here
about this story
[Music]
you